that out of here and then the walk-up
delivery by mr. floats on cue a sixty
eight consecutive Jane's coming back
from that shoulder in and he gets the
lefty layup to go inside right this is a
team that wants to play off its defense
they have been tremendous on that on the
floor one of those free agent pickups he
was bought out by his former team and
signed with the 76ers with the finger
roll pulls poems finally found the
handle and knocked it down he's not
taking a ton of jump shots he doesn't
have to he's explosive he's got speed we
know for sure that read it takes great
care of his body and very fastidious
about his prepping his fitness TJ
McConnell with a corner jumper tipped
loose bulls comes up with it Belinelli
corner for a yes
[Applause]
the years Philadelphia continues to pile
it on again and again here well the
Buffs just getting fun their debates
tickets of concerns when members of the
team and the coaching staff are calling
you selfish at this late date but that
said it is really hard for me to scalp
discounting strong case for Quin Snyder
often this bolts inside both in that
long reach to hook that one home
teammates score it non homes inside he
is but look how confident and
comfortable holds his directing traffic
games MRSA state games and looks
comfortable here he is on the break
boats with a nice die McConnell with the
left
boats
homes